[Music]
we read it's best to have a guy who
really knows the country fortunately I
have such a friend Steven Yeun we've
been naked together huh those places too
they can be yeah I'm excited to show you
the country maybe now you're thrilled
were here just thrilled
let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
I am now about to enjoy a traditional
Korean meal Stephen can you tell me what
these dishes are yes you don't seem to
know do you know what this is
like what's that I've seen I've seen
that's a that's seriously you know it so
it looks like rice yeah you're my
cultural ambassador what I do eat is
potatoes so yes
I don't this was a this was a Jewish
delicatessen about 15 minutes ago
those look like pancakes yes yes Korean
pancakes pajeon pyjama yep has whatever
my mom puts in okay and then that is
fish cakes what your voice get so high
uncertainty
[Laughter]
this is coochie-coo or rigging chi or
one of those things which is essentially
teaching the water right you're sort of
like Anthony Bourdain if he knew
absolutely nothing under this is you I
believe this is a spoon of some may be a
spoon or a fork it could be a knife okay
let's not talk about the food you know
nothing about yeah we will eat the food
he knows nothing about sorry like this
Oh with spoon no that's not how you use
don't I have to use no you can use on
your hand this is counter-intuitive to
most
[Music]
[Applause]
you lose I win our ways are different
but who's to say which one is better I
mean yeah that's a better way
you